[Applause]
their goals are ambitious overthrow the
government rebuild as a segregated
nation and put the white race firmly in
control
they are the racists in it and their
numbers are increasing oh yeah we are
aiders you know we do hate you it's time
to leave and get out of our face or
you're gonna suffer the consequences
their equipment techniques are both
powerful and far-reaching leaving behind
the conventional uniform they've learned
to blend in to mainstream society to
attract new recruits you know we had a
run with a skinhead thing and it was fun
but then I said well it's time you know
go to college get a good education get
as high as you can an industry military
police whatever you can do and wait and
they know how to utilize some of the
best pulpits available today music and
the internet and many of America's youth
are listening kids are vulnerable
they're impressionable you can give them
a worldview at that stage in life that
they will act on pretty convincingly for
a long long time I mean any cult
recruits at that age online the racist
skinheads often code their messages to
create an in-group of knowing people
rahowa stands for racial holy war one
four signifies the fourteen words that
stand for the racist skinhead main
mission to symbolize Heil Hitler they
use a numeric code based on the eighth
letter of the alphabet HH is coded as 88
white supremacists are very visually
oriented I mean you can think back to
the 3rd right and how visually oriented
the Nazis were they want people to
notice those symbols and they're
designed to cause fear since the
Internet can reach an unprecedented
number of people in an instant these
websites are where racist skinheads can
influence alienated youth you search on
you know Adolf Hitler you search under
Nazism you get a lot of modern-day Nazi
websites they start telling you you know
you think this way but here's the truth
your parents are lying to you the
government's lying to you and they start
brainwashing you you start talking them
on a regular basis and you know you
start believing in the rhetoric the
other major vehicle for recruitment is
music
culture and music in particular is a way
to reach the ears if not the hearts of
new generation because it's the music of
rebellion it's the music of telling your
parents on telling society it's the
music of expressing adolescent read each
record companies like label 56 are
impacting America's vulnerable audience
probably our most popular genres right
now our hardcore and metal that's more
or less like me someone over the head
with a two-by-four we get a message
across
there is a very shocking there very
brutal but sometimes that's what it
takes to awaken a young kid label 56
claims to run the second-largest white
power label in the u.s. selling
thousands of CDs every year to an
international audience
it really doesn't concern us too much
who gets our material obviously our
material is available to the public
books don't kill people movies don't
kill people music doesn't kill people
and guns don't kill people people kill
people with violence at the core the
racist skinheads message of racial pride
continues to spread to a growing
audience we're in the 21st century but
there's these folks who want to take us
back to the 19th century and reinforce
all the bigotry that's been the root of
the problem for so many centuries by not
letting us move past racism from super
codes to aggressive lyrics in metal
music racist skinheads are finding more
and more ways to promote their message
and fuel their revolution
[Applause]